in my book i really hold out people in
recovery from severe addiction
as sort of modern day profits for the
rest of us because i do think that
people who have been addicted and then
go get into recovery
do have a hard one wisdom
um that we can all benefit from
and and the wisdom
i guess
you know to distill it down i mean it's
it's many things
but in terms of
you know dopamine the wisdom is there
are
adaptive ways to get your dopamine
and there are less than adaptive ways
and in general
you could describe the adaptive ways as
not too potent so not tipping that
balance too hard or too fast to the side
of pleasure so does that mean never
allowing myself to be absolutely
incomplete bliss or does it mean not
allowing myself to stay in that state
too long the latter i think the latter
so and then that gets to temperament so
i'm going to get that to a second so so
in general what we want is some kind of
flexibility in that balance and the
ability to re easily reassert
homeostasis we don't want to break our
balance which is possible if we over
indulge for enough period of time and
end up with a balanced tip to the side
of pain this dopamine deficit state
we've been talking about we want to we
want a flexible resilient balance right
which can be sensitive to things going
on in the environment which can
experience pleasure and approach which
can experience pain and recoil right
this is all adaptive and healthy and
necessary and good we would never want a
balance that doesn't tilt right that
would be a disaster right we wouldn't be
human
and we wouldn't want that be really
really boring on the other hand what
people in recovery from addiction talk
about is
to some extent having to learn to live
with
things being a little boring a lot of
the time right so trying to avoid some
of this intensity and
thrill-seeking and escapism that really
is at the core of addictive tendencies
sorry to intro but when you say boring
um can we add stressful and boring yes
so anxiety and boredom can hang out
together right
am i correct
oh for sure i mean actually boredom is
highly anxiety provoking okay that's
good to know because i think people hear
boredom and they think
like oh there's nothing to do here right
i feel like we have a ton to do we just
don't really want to do it right as
opposed to something that we're excited
to do right okay so so that this gets to
sort of some of the core things also we
were talking about earlier about finding
your passion so i'm going to try to link
it all together um but basically it's a
boredom first of all boredom is a rare
experience for modern humans because
we're constantly distracting ourselves
from the present moment and we have an
infinite number of ways to do that right
um but boredom is really i think an
important and necessary experience
but it is scary because when you allow
yourself to be bored um let's say you
were had that list of all the things you
hate to do when you actually got them
all done imagine that and you got your
forthcoming book done
and you did all your interviews
and it didn't happen lightning could be
right and you walked your dog and you
cleaned your house and you went shopping
imagine that for a moment you would be
sitting in your house and my guess is
you would be terrified
because wow
what am i supposed to do now right
there's nothing i really have to do and
that is really really scary that can
feel like free fall and yet that's
really an important and good experience
to have and i think that is an
experience out of which
we can have a lot of creative
initiative but also really consider our
priorities and values okay here i am on
planet earth what the hee how am i going
to do with my life what do i really care
about how do i really want to spend my
time when i'm not distracting myself you
know in order to spend it
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
anna lemke and my take on our top 10
rules of success enjoy
rule number two have a balance how often
i grab my phone to distract me from
difficult times whether it's serious
life challenges i'll look at it because
i don't want to deal with that in this
present moment from minor life
challenges like something scary on tv i
grab my phone because i don't want to
look at it
and so
you know when you talk about all the
different instances like escaping drugs
alcohol romance novels binge watching
netflix whatever it is that we do
why does this only make our challenges
in life worse that we're not able to be
in the present moment
yeah great question i think to really
understand
why we need to pay attention to this
problem
and why it's non-trivial
is to understand the neuroscience of
pleasure and pain and the way that i
explain this to my patients and to my
medical students is as i say
imagine that
in your brain there's a balance kind of
like a teeter-totter in a kid's
playground
and in its resting state unlike a
teeter-totter in a kid's playground that
balance is level with the ground
that balance represents
how our brain processes pleasure and
pain and they work like opposite sides
of a balance
when we do something pleasurable or
reinforcing let's say in my case i eat a
pita piece of chocolate my balance tilts
slightly to the side of pleasure i get a
little release of dopamine our pleasure
neurotransmitter in the brain
and i feel good
but one of the overriding rules
governing this balance is that it wants
to stay level it doesn't want to remain
very long to the side of pleasure or the
site of pain
so the brain will immediately respond to
that or adapt to it by down regulating
our own dopamine production and down
regulating our own dopamine transmission
i kind of imagine this as these little
gremlins hopping on the pain inside of
the balance to bring it level again
but the gremlins like it on the balance
so they stay on until it's tipped in
equal and opposite amount to the side of
pain and that's the after effect the
come down the hangover that moment of
wanting one more piece of chocolate now
if we wait long enough the gremlins hop
off and homeostasis is restored and
we're back at our sort of level set
point for experiencing pleasure and pain
and that's fine then we move on
but if we continue to tap our phones or
watch you know netflix or read romance
novels or eat more chocolate we
eventually end up with so many gremlins
on the pain side of the balance that
they could fill this whole room and when
we've reached that point we've
essentially changed our set point for
experiencing pleasure and pain such that
we need more and more of the pleasurable
stimulus and more potent forms to get
the same effect and importantly when
we're not ingesting
that pleasurable substance our balance
is tilted sharply to the side of pain
we experience the universal symptoms of
withdrawal anxiety irritability
restlessness insomnia mental
preoccupation with our drug and it can
stay like that for a very very long time
so this is not just about tolerance and
needing more to get the same effect it's
about the fact that when we're not using
we are essentially in a dopamine deficit
state right we're walking around unhappy
i see so many patients coming in
reporting depression anxiety insomnia
wanting me to help them
one of the first interventions that i
make is to have them eliminate their
drug of choice whatever it is for one
month
and i warn them they're good they're
going to feel worse before they feel
better because it'll be the pleasure
pain balance tilted here but if they can
just abstain for long enough
those neural adaptation of gremlins will
hop off the balance and homeostasis will
be restored and they'll
again be able to take pleasure in life's
more modest rewards so ultimately the
thesis of dopamine nation is that both
as individuals and as a larger society
we have inundated ourselves with so much
dopamine that we've reset our pleasure
pain pathways to the side of pain making
it harder for us to experience pleasure
and more likely that we will experience
pain rule number three understand the
gateway effect this is just one of many
typical examples of cases that i have
seen in my career and you'll note this
one was in 2017.
this was a 28 year old male he had a
diagnosis of chronic pain there was no
known disease or tissue damage to to
explain his pain but nonetheless he had
pain from the tops of his top of his
head to the tips of his toes and he was
on the falling regimen prescribed to him
by his very purportedly very nice and i
believe it well-educated primary care
doctor 40 milligrams of opana and opioid
twice a day 30 milligrams of dilated and
opioid once a day 60 milligrams of
oxycodone and opioid once a day 20
milligrams of valium of benzodiazepine
once a day 65 milligrams of
phenobarbital a sedative 30 milligrams
of tomazepam once a day and no list
would be complete without eight
milligrams of xanax once a day
so this young man with no known disease
etiology other than the endorsement of
having a severe chronic pain which i
believe he has is at imminent risk
for overdose death with this regimen
uh and just to kind of put that in
perspective he's on 470
morphine milligram equivalents daily the
average heroin addicted person takes
about approximately 100 morphine
milligram equivalents daily so all of
this prescribed by the doubt by a doctor
a good doctor a well-educated doctor and
sanctioned by our modern health care
system
now we're in what's been called the
second and third waves of the epidemic
what you'll see here is that
approximately
around 2013 or so there was a spike in
heroin related overdose deaths by the
way you'll note here this is
prescription opioid related deaths which
has plateaued i mean maybe even gone
down slightly but is still pretty darn
high right and then you have this spike
in heroin and then right here
synthetic opioids especially fentanyl
which we know is 50 to 100 times more
potent
than than heroin is so what happened how
do we understand this
basically the first way to understand
this is the gateway effect that
essentially vicodin oxycontin percocet
got folks addicted and the natural
progression of addiction is that people
look for more and more potent sources
and cheaper sources price point really
matters when people become addicted and
so they've gone from prescription
opioids to illicit sources as those
became cheaper and more available
also partially explaining this is the
fact that as we have pulled back on
opioid prescribing individuals can now
no longer get the opioids that they used
to get for their doctor than their
doctor some of those individuals are now
going to the illicit market and then of
course very importantly the tsunami
effect right
just the fact that all of those pills
are in all of those medicine cabinets
means that for some vulnerable teenagers
they just really have to get one
prescription and try it once and then
they're often running to illicit sources
so unfortunately what we're seeing is
that doctors fearful of repercussions
for opioid prescribing in the context of
this epidemic are now no longer being
willing to treat some patients with pain
this was a study that was done where
there was a confederate who pretended to
be the child of an older person with
pain who called the michigan primary
care clinic and said will you treat my
father or my mother there on this opioid
regimen 40 of primary care clinics in
michigan said we're not going to treat
uh your your parent we won't even see
them as a patient so this is part of the
repercussion
uh it's gotten so bad as you can see
here this is just another example of the
fact that many high school students who
get addicted to prescription opioids
started with
a prescription from their doctor
and here's an interesting statistic in
the 1960s 80 percent of heroin users
started with heroin today if you
interview heroin users 75 percent of
them will tell you that they started
with a prescription opioid again a very
different phenomenology in terms of this
epidemic
okay so what i want to do next is delve
a little bit more deeply into how this
happened rule number four challenge the
anxiety you've got this um
it's a chart that has
chocolate sex nicotine
amphetamines on it
it talks about how much dopamine is
released with chocolate versus sex and
drugs and you also see that learning
increases dopamine firing in the brain
so i wonder where do healthier habits
like learning or exercise fit into this
chart and should we be cautious of too
much learning or too much exercise do we
get the surplus with healthy things as
well
yeah great question so so how do we
differentiate good dopamine from bad
dopamine or healthy adaptive sources of
dopamine from less healthy or adaptive
sources
the chart you're referring to has to do
with an experiment where they placed a
probe in a rat's brain to figure out how
much dopamine is released in the rat's
brain when it ingests certain substances
and um you know dopamine is a
neurotransmitter which means it's a it's
a molecule in the brain that's
intimately associated with pleasure
reward and motivation
neurotransmitters are the molecules that
bridge the synapse between two neurons
so neurons communicate through
electrical signals but they don't touch
end to end there's a little gap and
that's to be able to regulate and
control those signals and that gap is
bridged by little chemicals that are
called neurotransmitters
dopamine is probably the most important
neurotransmitter involved in reward
motivation and pleasure it's not the
only neurotransmitter but it's probably
the final common pathway so measuring
dopamine in a rat's brain
with ingestion of certain substances
gives some idea of how reinforcing that
substance is and as you saw we we all
have tonic baseline amounts of dopamine
firing in our brain so it's not as if we
have no dopamine and then we get
dopamine we're always firing a little
bit of dopamine and it's how dopamine
changes either above or below baseline
firing that creates our
emotional states when dopamine goes
above baseline that's the feeling of
pleasure motivation reward when dopamine
goes below baseline that's the feeling
of craving irritability anxiety
restlessness
and what that that experiment showed is
that chocolate increases um dopamine
firing above baseline about 50 units sex
is about 100 units
um nicotine i think is 150 cocaine is
250 and amphetamine is a thousand
so you get some sort of sense of sort of
relative
reinforcing potential of those different
drugs
now importantly there's also this idea
of drug of choice so what makes your
dopamine go up to a hundred might not
make my dopamine levels go up to
hundreds so there's also that
inter-individual variability but getting
to your question about sort of exercise
or learning
these are activities that are not
immediately releasing dopamine
with the initial stimulus
they they come as sort of an after
effect which is why i talk about
pressing on the pain side of the balance
in order to reset our pleasure pathways
to the pleasure side so remember
repeatedly pressing on the pleasure side
has the gremlins hopping on the pain
side and basically resets our thresholds
to the side of pain but if we
intentionally
engage in challenging painful or anxiety
provoking activities that is we press on
the pain side then those same neural
adaptation gremlins will hop on the
pleasure side to bring us ultimately to
this point so that's the good kind of
dopamine
and typically that means you know again
in small doses doing things that are
hard learning is usually effortful and
hard
exercise is usually effortful and hard
i'm exposing ourselves to things that
we're afraid of is effortful and hard
and all of that in small doses
is good for us because then you don't
get your dopamine from the initial
stimulus you get it from the opponent
process stimulus and one of the other
you know
experiments that i talk about in the
book which is
kind of horrific to read because
you know it's very inhumane to dogs and
it was done some time ago but to me it's
it's a really fascinating experiment
basically they took dogs and they
exposed them to a very strong electrical
shock so they pressed down very hard on
the pain side of the balance and
initially after the initial response you
know the dog was sort of wary and
alarmed and you know defecated and
urinated on itself kind of horrible but
what's really fascinating is with the
second exposure of the shock
the
brain compensated
by tipping the balance inside of
pleasure and the dog exhibited a what
the
what the researchers called a fit of joy
right after being released from from the
the the
the electrical harness the dog bounced
up and down was happy you know was and
that's that's not just like oh thank
goodness you know i'm no longer being
shocked that's actually a physiologic
reaction
to a stressor that there's this opponent
process reaction or this counter effect
leading to
you know euphoria and dopamine it's the
same thing people get a runner's high or
what have you
now is it possible to overdo painful
stimuli to get addicted to exercise
absolutely and i see patients like that
who run so much or exercise so much they
end up injured and yet keep going that's
a situation where you have
too much of a good thing even if it's
you know
sort of a painful stimulus can be bad
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five don't over
indulge when we find something or when
something finds us
that we enjoy that feels pleasurable uh
social media food right sex
gambling whatever happens to be and we
will explore the full range of these
there's a some dopamine release when we
engage in that behavior
and then what you're telling me is that
very quickly yes and beneath my
conscious awareness there's a
tilting back of the scale
where pleasure is reduced by way of
increasing pain right
and i've heard you say before
that
the pain
mechanism
has some competitive advantages over the
pleasure mechanism such that it doesn't
just bring the scale back to level it
actually brings pain higher than
pleasure
could you tell us a little bit more
about that yeah yeah so so what happens
again so the the the hallmark of any
addictive substance or behavior is that
it releases a lot of dopamine in our
brains reward pathway like right like
broccoli just doesn't release a lot of
dopamine just doesn't right but what
happens right after i do something that
is really pleasurable and releases a lot
of dopamine is again my brain is going
to immediately compensate by
down regulating my own dopamine
receptors my own dopamine transmission
to compensate for that okay
and that's that come down or the
hangover or that after effect that
moment of wanting to do it more now if i
just wait for that feeling to pass
then my dopamine will re-regulate itself
and i'll go back to whatever my chronic
baseline is but if i don't wait and
here's really the key if i keep
indulging again and again and again
ultimately
i have i have so much on the pain side
right that i've essentially reset my
brain to what we call like an an hedonic
or lacking in joy
type of state which is a dopamine
deficit state so that's really the the
way in which
pain can become the main driver is
because i've indulged so much in these
high reward behaviors or substances that
my brain has had to compensate by way
down regulating my own dopamine such
that even when i'm not doing that drug
i'm in a dopamine deficit state which is
akin to a clinical depression i have
anxiety irritability insomnia dysphoria
and a lot of mental preoccupation with
using again or getting the drug and so
that that's the piece there there's the
single use
which
easily passes but it's the chronic use
that can then reset
really our dopamine thresholds and then
nothing is enjoyable
right that then everything sort of pales
in comparison to this one drug that i
want to keep doing rule number six don't
monetize the work you could also say
that someone who enjoys working as well
is that the same thing you
get addicted to the stress of your job
the same idea yeah i mean
absolutely so i mean again i think being
very engaged in your work and finding
meaning and purpose in your work can be
a really good source of dopamine but
anything that leads to you know that
kind of reinforcement loop has the
potential to become addictive and one of
the points of dopamine nation is the way
that technology has made all of these
behaviors including work potentially
more potent and hence more addictive so
for example the way that we're now
measured in the metrics used for work
are often remote from the meaning of the
work itself so for example you know we
may for example in in medicine we
actually get metrics telling us how many
patient hours we've built and how much
above our target we get graphs and all
of a sudden you can begin to monetize
that experience
in a way that's in and of itself
reinforcing that is separate from the
actual reason for doing the work in the
first place and that can then lead to
this kind of vicious cycle of compulsive
over-engagement or addiction rule number
seven look around you one of the big
problems now that's very misguided about
this idea of finding your passion
it's almost as if people are looking to
fit the key into the lock of the thing
that was meant for them to do right and
then everything will feel like a natural
person right and then everything will be
wonderful i can attest to the fact that
is not how it works yeah any endeavor
right and that you'll have all this
great
i really success
the answer lies and i really really
believe this stop looking for your
passion
and instead look around right where you
are
stop distracting yourself look around
right where you are and see what needs
to be done
so not what do i want to do but what is
the work that needs to be done and more
importantly it doesn't have to be some
grandiose work like does the garbage
need to be taken out right is there some
garbage on your neighbor's lawn that
someone threw there that you could
actually bend over and pick up and put
into the garbage can
look around you there is so much work
that needs to be done that nobody wants
to do that is really really important
and if we all did that i really think
the world would be a much better place
and this is what people who have severe
addiction who get into recovery realize
they're like it's not about me and my
will and what i'm going to will in my
life or in the world it's about looking
around what needs to be done what is the
work that i am called to do in this
moment which also is incredibly freeing
because i don't have to search for the
perfect thing there's a lot of burden
now on young people that they have to
find that perfect thing and until
they've found that perfect thing they're
going to be miserable you don't have to
do that look at the life you were given
look at the people around you look at
the jobs that present themselves to you
and do that job simply and honorably one
day at a time in a with a kind of
humility i think this is really what
what's so striking to me about the
wisdom of people in recovery there's
this incredible humility that comes out
of that experience you feel so broken so
ashamed but you pick yourself up one day
at a time and you build a life that's
around
what can i do
right in this moment that might benefit
another person and thereby benefit me
rule number eight watch the cravings
what motivates the drug seeking patient
for me what was really revelatory when i
first started learning about addiction
was to learn something about the
neuroscience of addiction and how the
brain changes so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to condense like the last 50
years of addiction neuroscience into
three minutes at a level at which i
understand it it will become immediately
apparent that i'm not a neuroscientist
but here we go
one of the most interesting things that
we've learned in the past 50 years about
pain and pleasure is that they're
co-located
so the same areas of the brain that
process pleasure
are the areas that process pain
and the way that pain and pleasure
interrelate is that they work like a
balance okay so i really like chocolate
so when i take in just a piece of
chocolate my balance tips slightly to
the side of pleasure
but here's the thing about the balance
it wants to remain level and it will
work very hard to re-establish a level
balance or what is called homeostasis
and it does that through a process
called neuro-adaptation
now
i kind of imagine neuroadaptation as
these little gremlins hopping on the
pain side of my balance to bring it
level again
and that's that moment of wanting a
second piece of chocolate because the
thing about the gremlins is they like it
on the balance they don't hop off as
soon as it's level but they wait till
the balance is tipped in equal and
opposite amount to this side of pain
again that's why i'm thinking another
piece of chocolate would be really good
right now
if i wait long enough the gremlins hop
off the balance reasserts homeostasis
and i'm not really craving another piece
of chocolate
that's how it works okay now imagine
that instead of a piece of chocolate my
doctor gives me some vicodin and by the
way i'm in pain so i'm not even starting
out with a level balance right i'm
starting out tilted to the side of pain
but the balance works the same way
now i don't get a little bit of shift to
the side of pleasure i get a great big
shift
huge amount of dopamine in my reward
pathway the fundamental difference
between substances that are addictive
and those that are not is the amount of
dopamine that they release in the reward
pathway so now i need a great big arnold
schwarzenegger size grandma on the pain
side to bring my balance level again but
remember it doesn't stay there it slams
down to the side of pain that is called
opioid withdrawal it's extremely painful
for some people but you know it lasts
hours to days depending on how many
opioids you took the gremlin hops off
and homeostasis reasserts itself now
here is the key piece to understanding
the disease of addiction
if i take that opioid for days two weeks
to months to years
i have enough gremlins on the pain side
of my balance to fill this entire
auditorium
right
because now my balance is working really
hard to adapt to all those exogenous
opioids
so if i can't get more opioids if i just
say decide my life is a mess i want to
stop guess what i slam down to the side
of pain
and it doesn't just take hours or days
for those gremlins to hop off it takes
weeks to months to years
and this is what we call craving
i am now walking around with this type
of balance i'm irritable i'm anxious i'm
depressed i'm maybe even suicidal i
can't sleep my life is a lot better i
got my job back i got my kids back i got
my husband back
but i feel like crap right
theoretically if i wait long enough the
gremlins hop off
and i get a level bounce and i can enjoy
a piece of chocolate again
but maybe for some people that doesn't
ever happen
which is where we get this idea that
we can use opioids to treat opioid
addiction in some cases rule number nine
try the 30-day dopamine fast being aware
of
what's pushing us too far
is important and then when you say when
you find something that pushes you too
far you try your 30-day fast and then
can you explain your dopamine acronym
that you have
so that we know
how to go through the steps
so i mean i think the first step the d
of dopamine stands for data and that's
just trying to be very honest with
ourselves about what is the behavior or
the substance that we have a conflicted
relationship with either
it's led to problems in our lives or we
just know we're consuming too much of it
or spending too much time getting it or
thinking about it or covering it up
um and then be being really honest with
ourselves about exactly what the data
are you know how often are we using it
how much are we using what are we using
um you know what are
what what's the consumption level
and the o of the dopamine acronym stands
for objectives why do we use what does
it do for us does it numb us does it
give us pleasure uh does it help with
depression does it help us sleep you
know what what is the thing that's
that's driving our use the p of dopamine
stands
for problems associated with you so then
being really honest with ourselves like
what what is it that's not working maybe
it worked initially and it's not working
anymore because of this pleasure pain
balance or maybe it's still kind of
working but now we're lying about it or
our spouse is unhappy with it or we're
not able to be present for our children
in the way that we want to be
and then the a of dopamine stands for
abstinence where we basically
do a dopamine fast we take a break from
that substance or behavior for one month
now one month is the ideal because
typically it takes about 10 to 14 days
for acute withdrawal to resolve for the
gremlins to start to hop off the pain
side of the balance and for homeostasis
to be restored
and that's why i i say a month because
by the time folks get to week three or
four they're really noticing the
benefits of not using and that's the key
to get past that initial withdrawal and
get to that point we're like ah you know
i i get it now i was totally hooked and
i didn't see it
um but if you can't do a month because
of you know work or whatever the
circumstances is
you can't totally eliminate the device
for example maybe just eliminate the
apps that are that are causing
difficulty or some aspect of it that's
causing difficulty and or maybe just
eliminate it for a single day i mean
even you know a digital sabbath one day
a week can be really instructive for
folks
and then just quickly the rest of the
acronym the m stands for mindfulness
that means
really just sitting with those
uncomfortable and restless feelings when
we're in acute withdrawal and noticing
but not trying to change those feelings
not trying to reach for something to get
rid of that feeling this is a really
hard thing to do
um the eye of dopamine stands for
insight this is where we become aware of
just how addicted we we are
or we were something that's really hard
to do when we're in it
um the n stands for next step so if we
make it that full month then we think
about okay do i want to continue to
abstain or do i want to go back to using
and if so how do i want to use most of
my patients want to go back to using
their drug of choice they want to use
less they want to use differently so
this is where we talk about self-finding
strategies and specific barriers that we
can put in place
so that we don't get caught up in that
cycle of compulsive overconsumption and
then you know when we give it a try and
that's the e of the dopamine that's the
experiment part
we say to ourselves okay i'm not going
to drink at home i'm only going to drink
with friends i'm only going to drink
wine i'm only going to have one glass
and we just see if we can do it and you
know then a month later sort of collect
the data again and start again and rule
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is avoid dependence
do you think if if you're giving
somebody something at a high enough dose
over a long enough period of time it's
possible to addict anyone to almost
anything
yes
i i do think so
um you know and certainly
most people for example who take an
opioid like a vicodin or
oxycontin or a norco
who take that daily will develop
physiologic dependence on that such that
if they try to decrease it or stop it
they'll go into withdrawal now physical
dependence
and addiction are not exactly the same
thing but there's a very high
correlation between those two things and
in terms of what's going on in the brain
it's not really clear if there's a
difference or what that difference might
be
the current opioid epidemic is in fact
the canary in the coal mine for our
faltering health care system that in
fact opioids became the solution not to
patient's problems but to doctors
problems
in order to really understand how that
came about i think it's it's important
to understand what drives and motivates
the compassionate doctor because at the
end of the day it's not the pill mill
doctor who's lost their moral compass
but the compassionate doctor
behind this opioid epidemic
so what motivates the compassionate
doctor well first and foremost people
who go into medicine tend to be pleasers
they tend to be people who want to help
the other people i would even argue that
they're kind of natural codependents
not just speaking for myself but myself
included
they're also people who are really good
at figuring out complex systems
including the school system to get to
the top of their class to get into
medical school in the first place
there are also people who are responding
to a higher calling right they go into
medicine because they want to save lives
and alleviate suffering this becomes a
primary motivator for them in their
practice
as they as we go through medical
practice we're very heavily socialized
to put ourselves in our patients shoes
to imagine their suffering we get very
little training on what to do if our
patients may be manipulating or
deceiving us
and in the 1990s in addition to there
being this paradigm shift in the
treatment of pain this was also the
beginning of what was called the
evidence
evidence-based movement in medicine this
idea that we would eliminate quackery by
basing everything we do in data and
therefore we wouldn't have to you know
it would all be purely scientific
unfortunately what happened which i'll
soon show is that the pharmaceutical
industry co-opted the so-called science
to convince doctors that opioid
prescribing was rooted in science when
in fact there is no science to support
it
this is a great quote by william bruce
cameron which i love not everything that
counts can be counted and not everything
that can be counted counts we forgot
about this in medicine all of a sudden
it became not okay to rely on your
clinical judgment your clinical
experience or god forbid your intuition
everybody had to wave a number around
and then ultimately in order to
understand what drives the compassionate
doctor you really need to know that what
makes us get up and out of bed in the
morning and going to work again and
again is that we're going to have that
kind of bubarian eye and thou encounter
with our patients where we can realize
our identity as a healer and our
patients expresses gratitude it's those
moments that we really look for and if
we were to challenge our patient about
the way that they're taking a pill we're
prescribing it really threatens that
mutual affection that is part of how
docs get their dopamine what is dopamine
and
what are maybe some things about
dopamine that most people don't know and
probably that i don't know either
so dopamine is a neurotransmitter and
neurotransmitters are those molecules
that bridge the gap between two neurons
so they essentially allow one neuron the
presynaptic neuron to communicate with
the postsynaptic neuron
dopamine is intimately
associated with the experience of reward
but also with movement which i think is
really interesting because movement and
reward are linked right if you think
about you know
early humans
you had to move in order to go seek out
the water or the the meat or whatever it
was
and even in the most primitive organisms
dopamine is released when food is sensed
in the environment for example c elegans
a very um primitive worm
so dopamine is this really
powerful important
molecule in the brain
that helps us um experience pleasure
it's not the only neurotransmitter
involved in pleasure but it's a really
really important one
and if if you want to think about
something that most people don't know
about dopamine which which i think is
really interesting is that we we are
always releasing dopamine at a kind of
tonic baseline rate and it's really the
deviation from that baseline rather than
like hits of dopamine in a vacuum that
make a difference so when we experience
pleasure our dopamine release goes above
baseline and likewise dopamine can go
below that tonic baseline and then we
experience a kind of pain
interesting so is it fair to say that
one's baseline levels of dopamine how
frequently we are releasing dopamine in
the absence of some uh i don't know drug
or food or experience
just sitting being
is that associated with how happy
somebody is their kind of baseline of
happiness or level of depression
there is evidence that shows that
people who are depressed may indeed have
lower
tonic
levels of dopamine so that's a really
reasonable thought and there is some
evidence to suggest that that may be
true the other thing that we know and
this is you know
really kind of what
what the book is about is that if we
expose ourselves chronically to
substances or behaviors that
repeatedly release large amounts of
dopamine in our brain's reward pathway
that we can change our tonic baseline
and actually lower it over time as our
brain tries to compensate for all of
that dopamine which is more really than
we were designed to to
experience what we decided to do my
husband and i was that we we ourselves
now this is our eldest was born in 2001.
we decided to not have smartphones
ourselves and not get wi-fi to the house
we decided it would be harder to
moderate our use than to simply
not
have those devices and that kind of
access
from the home
he and i both had big computer setups at
work and so we really kept it very
siloed and discreet our online
engagement
and i have to say that that worked
really well um you know when our kids
were little
um they
didn't spend a lot of time on screens
they did develop
you know other other skills and outlets
we did a lot of outdoor activities in
nature and sports we really emphasized
you know positive
exercise and sleep and things like that
family time
not on screens
but by the time our eldest got got into
high school she basically came home and
said i cannot function as a high school
student without wi-fi to the to the
house and when we investigated that we
found that that was true so we got wi-fi
to the house and then she came home a
couple weeks later having purchased her
very own iphone and her own iphone plan
and said i can't function socially as a
teenager without my own phone and really
andrea it's been downhill since then
well
we just got a phone for my seventh
grader
who said the same thing she said i can't
do these problems in class they say take
out your phones and she was the only one
sitting there so it got to a point where
we had to cave but we were
on the same vein as you trying to hold
off as long as we could right and i
think you know that's what i would i do
think that these problems
to a certain extent can be addressed in
the nuclear family
um and my advice to parents is to
severely limit screen time for your
children as long as you can which is
about to age 12 or 13 and then
essentially you know it's over between
the schools and their friends they will
see what they will see but if you can
have
the dialogue about it um you know and
what i mean what i mean by the dialogue
is what i write about in dopamine nation
explain the neuroscience to kids explain
that this can be an addictive drug um
you know talk about
about what are some of the warning signs
and how to limit the sort of um
escalating use toward addiction
and the importance simply of doing that
right even just having the conversation
about the fact that it is a drug and
that we must be mindful
about the way that we're using these
devices is is a really good starting
place
and then just continue to have these
conversations continue to reflect back
to
you know our children what we see about
their use which concerns us what we hear
from others about what they're putting
online which concerns us because you
know
invariably there will be mistakes made
and so you know it's just a constant
constant discussion at home who's
prescribing all of these pills
we'll read a lot about so-called pill
mill doctors these are doctors who are
willfully exchanging prescriptions for
cash these are doctors who have lost
their moral compass
certainly
those kinds of doctors exist they have
always existed but if you think that
pill mill doctors are the primary driver
of this epidemic then you have
misunderstood it
this epidemic is not the result of a
small subset of prolific prescribers we
are all prescribing too many opioids
this is a study that we published in
jama where we looked at the medicare
database from 2013 to see who's
prescribing opioids
and really the most important take-home
message from our study was that again
it's not a small subset of prolific
prescribers driving this that everybody
in medicine is prescribing too many
opioids no matter what your medical
specialty
if you look at it by volume it's
internal medicine and family medicine
doctors as well as nurse practitioners
because there are more of them if you
look at it by specialty it's pain
doctors which makes sense but really the
bottom line is that everybody in
medicine today prescribes too many
opioids for minor and chronic pain
conditions
this is from the national survey of drug
use and health
the take home message from this image is
that great big yellow circle is the more
than 11 million people in this country
who misuse prescription opioids okay so
we're not talking about heroin we're not
talking about illicit fentanyl we're
talking about more than 11 million
people in this country who are
developing some kind of opioid use
disorder or addiction now compare that
to this much smaller circle which is the
approximately million people who use
heroin also a huge problem but again i
just want to make sure that you leave
today understanding that heroin is a
huge problem in this country fentanyl
illegal fentanyl is a huge problem but
prescription opioids are the origins of
this epidemic and continue to be a very
significant problem
where are people getting the
prescription opioids that they're
misusing well what you'll see here is
that about 35 get them from a single
prescriber
the large section here is those who get
them from a friend or family member many
of whom got them from a single
prescriber
what this gets at is that whether
directly or indirectly
prescribers are the major conduit of
misused prescription drugs in this
country this also importantly speaks to
something that i've called the tsunami
effect
part of what has driven this opioid
epidemic is not just people getting
addicted through their doctor's
prescriptions but the huge increase in
pills in medicine cabinets across the
country that teenagers and other people
also have access to i think that life
for humans has always been hard
but i think that now it's
harder in unprecedented ways
and i think that the way that life is
is really hard now is that it actually
is really boring
and the reason that it's boring is
because
all of our survival needs are met right
i mean we don't even have to leave our
homes to meet every single physical need
you know as long as you're of a certain
level of financial well-being which
frankly um you know we talk so much
about you know the the income gap and
certainly there is this enormous gap
between rich and poor but that gap is
smaller than it's ever been in like the
history of humans um even the poorest of
the poor have more
excess income to spend on leisure goods
than they ever have before in human
history if you look at leisure time for
example so
people without a high school education
have 42 percent more leisure time than
people with
um a college degree
um so so
my point here is that
life is hard now in this really weird
way
in that we don't really have anything
that we have to do
so we're all forced to make stuff up you
know whether it's being a scientist or
being a doctor
or being an olympic athlete
or you know climbing mount everest
and people really vary in their need for
friction and some people need a lot more
than others and if they don't have it
they're really really unhappy and i do
think that a lot of the people that i
see with addiction and other forms of
mental illness
are people who
need more friction like they're unhappy
not necessarily because there's
something wrong with their brain but
because their brain is not suited to
this world last week i had hermann
ponceron who
and they're not struggling with
addiction they're living in their
natural environment
yes i mean one of the main points i make
in dopamine nation is that we are living
in a time of unprecedented access
to highly reinforcing
drugs and behaviors
and that the smartphone is essentially
the equivalent of the hypodermic needle
delivering digital dopamine 24 7. and
our primitive brains have really not
evolved for this environment so it's
really the mismatch between our our
brains and the world that we've created
which has led to a lot of suffering if
you look at the top reasons for
death and disease across the globe
it's related to our sedentary lifestyle
our diet and and to addiction when
people come to see you and they're
anxious and they're they're saying i
need some help do they know it's because
they've played too many video games or
did they know that do we know what
dopamine surplus is yeah great question
so they almost always don't recognize
that as a potential cause
the way they experience it is that
their cannabis or alcohol or video games
are self-medicating the depression and
the anxiety and the insomnia and the
boredom and whatever it is what they
don't realize is that by continually
engaging in those high reward behaviors
they're essentially driving or creating
the states of anxiety depression and
insomnia
that that is very hard to see right all
they know is that they feel bad in
general
and
using their drug gives them some
temporary relief which of course it does
because their balance is tilted the site
of pain and it restores homeostasis now
originally their drug might have done
this for them and made them happy but
again with repeated use it all it does
is bring them back here but it's all
relative right the brain is working
through this you know it's a different
theory of relativity to kind of restore
homeostasis which is why this period of
absence is so important because it
allows people to really see true cause
and effect like when we're in the cycle
we don't see it but when we get some
distance from it we can look back and
say oh wow i feel so much better now
that i've abstained for a month
and i look back and i it's kind of crazy
how i was using drug x y or z like it's
sort of a shock to me
and so it's that it's abstaining that
really gives that flash of insight there
is still
huge
geographic variability in opioid
prescribing in this country and we're
going to get into a little bit what may
be driving that but just take a look at
some of these data
in 2012 in the united states doctors
were writing on average 81 opioid
prescriptions per 100 persons in this
country
in 2017 which is the last year for which
we have reliable data that went down
that's the good news to 59 opioid
prescriptions per 100 persons but look
at the state of alabama in 2017 107
opioid prescriptions per 100 persons a
decrease from the 121 opioid
prescriptions that were being written in
alabama in 2012 but still you can see
we've got a long way to go
some counties have rates that are seven
times the national average
this is a heat map the darker red is
more opioid prescribing the lighter is
less opioid prescribing this is when we
peaked at 2012. watch what happens over
time keep your eye on alabama and the
southeastern united states
2017 we've made a lot of progress but
we're still not where we need to be
also look at this same heat map when you
divide it by county you'll note that
even in states where opioid prescribing
is relatively low there are counties
where there's a lot of opioid
prescribing going on
and if you compare how we're prescribing
today compared to the rest of the world
we're still prescribing three to four
times as many opioids as most other
developed countries more than 10 times
as many opioids as japan and here's an
interesting thing germany and canada
just switched places canada was in
second place now germany has moved up
one thing we know that's happening is
that mundi pharma and outreach of purdue
pharma has now taken its marketing
campaign to countries abroad
also at the same time that opioid
prescribing has been going down it
appears as if benzodiazepine prescribing
valium xanax adivanconepin is going up
in this country
along with associated deaths when
opioids and benzos are co-prescribed the
risk of accidental overdose goes up how
do people die from opioids well
basically they fall asleep they stop
breathing and they don't wake up again
because opioids slow down the heart rate
they slow down the respiratory drive
when you add xanax or valium to an
opioid that increases the risk of that
kind of sedation and accidental overdose
let's talk about the pleasure pain
balance and addiction and i've heard you
use this uh seesaw or balance scale
um
analogy before and i think it's a
wonderful one uh that really for me
clarified
what
addiction is at least at the mechanistic
level
yeah so to me one of the most
significant findings in neuroscience in
the last 75 years is that pleasure and
pain are co-located which means the same
parts of the brain that process pleasure
also process pain and they work like a
balance so when we feel pleasure our
balance tips one way when we feel pain
it tips in the opposite direction
and one of the overriding rules
governing this balance is that it wants
to stay level so it doesn't want to
remain tipped very long to pleasure or
to pain and with any deviation from
neutrality the brain will work very hard
to restore a level balance or what
scientists call homeostasis and the way
the brain does that is with any stimulus
to one side there will be a tip an equal
and opposite amount to the other side
it's like you have principal laws of
physics yes right right so like i like
to watch youtube videos when i watch
youtube videos of american idol you know
it tips to the side of pleasure
and then when i stop watching it um i
have a come down right which is a tip to
the equal and opposite amount um on the
other side and that's that moment of
wanting to watch one more youtube video
right yeah and i just want to um
interject there so
this moment of of wanting to watch
another
that is associated with pain uh i think
is
are we always aware of that happening
because you just described in a very
conscious way right but when i um
indulge in something i enjoy
i'm usually thinking about just wanting
more thing i don't think about the pain
i just think about more right so really
excellent point because we're mostly not
aware of it and it's also reflexive so
we it's not something that consciously
happens or that we're aware of unless we
really begin to pay attention and and
when we begin to pay attention we really
can become very aware of it in the
moment again it's like a falling away
like that you know you're on social
media and you know you get a good tweet
of something and then
you can't stop yourself because there's
this awareness a latent awareness that
as soon as i disengage from this
behavior i'm going to experience a kind
of a pain right of falling away
missing that feeling of wanting more of
it and of course one way to combat that
is to do it more right and more and more
and more so i think i think that is
really what i want people to tune into
and get an awareness around because once
you tune into it you can see it a lot
and then when you begin to see it you
have and if you you know keep the model
of the balance in mind i think it it
gives people
kind of a way to imagine
what they're experiencing on a
neurobiological level and understand it
and in that understanding get some
mastery over it which is really what
this is all about because ultimately
we do need to disengage right we can't
live in that space all the time right we
have other things we need to do and
there are also serious consequences that
come with trying to repeat and continue
that experience or that feeling is there
a way for a person to know
if something is going to be addictive
for them other than if they had maybe
relatives that were addictive because i
think about it like i've never been very
experimental it's like i've never had
desire to try cocaine or you know and so
what makes is that is this a novelty
seeking gene in different people because
to me like just like i don't like to
take prescription medicine because i'm
so afraid but what makes some people
more eager to engage in certain things
that have risk
well i mean you know there are
people have are born with different
temperaments
and some people are just naturally drawn
to risk and to adrenaline adrenaline
itself can be addictive
a huge surge of adrenaline all at once
releases a lot of dopamine in the reward
pathway which is why people can get
addicted to things like skydiving i mean
that actually happens
um
also we know that as a baseline
temperament if you if you're more
impulsive
um you're more likely to get addicted
and impulsivity
basically just means that there's kind
of no
no pause between having a thought to do
something or say something saying
something and just doing it or saying it
um it's kind of like there's no there's
no gap there
so impulsivity is correlated people who
have cognitive struggles are correlated
with having higher risk of addiction so
things like attention deficit disorder
people who have problems with executive
functioning future planning
those are those are things that confer
risk really any co-occurring mental
illness
um makes a person you know more
vulnerable to the problem of addiction
so there are lots of sort of correlates
that we can look at but i think one of
the important points too beyond the
correlates of our own brain and our own
temperament is simple access
so having more access to addictive
substances makes us
more vulnerable to that prior to 1980
doctors were reluctant to prescribe
opioids because they were afraid that
their patients would get addicted to
them and for good reason this country
had seen two prior opioid epidemics one
that started with soldiers using
morphine uh during the civil war that
culminated in the narcomania of the
early 1900s when heroin was sold next to
bayer aspirin as a cough and cold remedy
for babies by the way heroin is just
morphine with two acetyl groups added it
was supposed to be the non-addictive
alternative to morphine remember that
theme it will recur
then in the vietnam era we saw another
major opioid epidemic in this country
when our vets were coming home
addicted to opium one very interesting
thing about that that also is a
resonating theme is that when they came
back more than two-thirds of them had a
resolution of their opioid addiction
simply by being back in the united
states where they had decreased access
and then we have our current opiate
epidemic which in terms of scale and
impact in terms of mortality is
unrivaled in terms of any other
drug epidemic
in this country
basically what happened in the 1980s in
medicine is that doctors recognized we
were not doing enough to help patients
with pain the 1980s was also the advent
of the hospice movement imported from
europe when there was recognition that
people were dying in extremis there was
the idea that hey let's use opioids more
liberally to help people in extreme pain
and to help people at the very end of
life in other words what started out as
a very well-intentioned movement inside
medicine ultimately gave way to doctors
dispensing opioids like vending machines
to pretty much anybody who walked in the
office and said i have pain in other
words there was a cunion paradigm shift
inside of medicine where opioids became
first-line treatment for minor pain
conditions and also chronic pain
conditions they basically became the
default to treat pain period
and it's no coincidence that this
epidemic is in sync exactly with an
increase in opioid prescribing so opioid
prescribing in this country quadrupled
between the 1990s and about 2010 it
peaked in 2012 and along with that we
saw a quadrupling and opioid overdose
mortality
in this country one of the reasons that
i talk so much about moderation in the
book is because
there are many drugs today that we
simply cannot just eliminate from our
lives smart phones is one of them
most of us need them to function in our
job so how do we use them in a healthy
and adaptive way food is another example
obviously we can't eliminate food so how
do we engage with food in a way that is
not addictive but that of course allows
us to eat in a healthy way sex is
another one for people with sex
addiction you know i think a part of a
healthy life for many people is to have
some sexual activity but how do we then
differentiate you know addictive sexual
activity from healthy sexual activity so
this question of how to moderate
has really become very essential for
modern life
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there